welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Mayhew sterling professor
emeritus of political science professor
Mayhew is widely considered one of the
leading scholars on the American
Congress he has authored numerous works
on Congress political parties elections
and policy-making including Congress the
electoral connection divided we govern
America's Congress electoral
realignments parties and policies and
partisan balance he is a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts and Science a
member of the American Philosophical
society and the National Academy of
Sciences and a recipient of the James
Madison and Samuel J ELLs bells awards
for career contributions today we talked
with Professor Mayhew about his new book
the imprint of Congress welcome
professor may we had to be here yes so
let's start with an overview of your
book tell us about it well it is some
let's see the imprint of Congress okay
and what did what I yeah it's about I
want I want to want I'm writing about
the effect of the results of what
Congress does rather than whether it
looks good or whether it does what the
president wants us to do whatever
whether the public like what Congress is
doing it as you read the headlines and
generally speaking Congress is down in
the tank about I want in its it's a
history book it's over two and a quarter
centuries which is American history all
the way back to begin in Congress have
been here a long time and that's what it
I want to see a the imprint of Congress
and in a series of policy areas or let's
say agendas that have been out there are
challenges have been out there that and
see what Congress's role is and I've
planned this so that so that i'm looking
at let's say impulses impulses policy or
performance impulses that have that have
obtained across a whole bunch of
comparative relative appear countries at
different times like as in building a
welfare state or responding to the Great
Depression or handling debt and deficit
right
for that amount of building a nation in
the first place back here in the 1790s
so I'm looking I'm trying to look at
Congress's distinctive performance or
contribution to what went on and he's in
this succession of impulses regardless
of what if we like what they did we may
find appalling I mean the SUV of America
having to do with with that race is not
is not great after all going back there
and I mean blacks are not representative
african-americans represented in
Congress appropriately until fairly
recently so we have to realize that too
that's a that's about where we are okay
so you've been looking at Congress for
years now decades in fact what was the
impetus for you writing this book why
write it there's a particular spur I
would lose a conference at Columbia a
couple years ago and the people who were
invited were charged to do a paper about
Congress as a handler republic of
handler policies and public affairs i
wrote a long paper i took seriously the
charger wrote a paper that was a preface
to this and then expand a little bit
into a journal article and now it's
tripled in size into a book the books
almost finished okay also i made reading
i do a lot of reading yes i know i spend
my time DJ here so i come across a lot
of stuff out there in books about
American history but most a lot of it
not really principally about Congress
but in pinching on Congress is writing
about things policy areas and such so I
had I had you know I had stuff stacked
up to stocked up in my head that I could
draw on or in my notes and and also I I
was tired of doing or never right never
write the same book twice it's my view
go on to something different tried
something tackled something different go
after a different Buffalo right so what
was your methodology for the book how
did you do the research for it's
entirely from greeting it's entirely out
of secondary sources is nothing and the
way primary sources or interviews or
statistical data sets or whatever it's
about it's from secondary sources and
how many did you pull in t2 you always
well up in the hundred a secondary
sources journal articles books I mean
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
probably some economic history for
example a lot of very good economic
history talks about what Congress has
been up to and the consequences thereof
over the last time what in 25 years
okay so let's get to these impetuses
these impulses impulses yes sorry there
are 13 of them yeah how did you come up
with a 13 well what I look for was a
first it's transnational I wanted to get
I wanted I didn't want to look at local
American things I wanted to look at what
causes or impulse urgent challenges or
agendas that have transnational presence
over in England France and so forth
other countries at different times to
see how the u.s. fit into such
transnational impulses so that was that
was a very that was a guide to it all
right so and I wanted a big stuff big
stuff like building a welfare state or
responding to the depression of the
1930s or civil rights the civil rights
revolution after World War Two this is a
big big enterprise a big challenge
impulses okay yeah um let's pick one for
instance you know you can either go with
the debt crisis you're our environmental
challenges that we face yep what have
you found in terms of Congress's imprint
on those pick one all right well all
right we'll talk about both of them
gonna be fine look let's look at that
that definite that slide that deficit
right now that that that's lat good /
deficit okay now that's a problem and an
agenda and across the across the world
in the last few decades the big problem
I mean the economies were humming in the
50s 60s and 70s and the government's
lined out as bad money but then the
economies have been built growing most
slowly since about nineteen seventy
three which is put pressure on npn
governments like this band is it p so
what's pressure all over the place so
it's a very common problem and it's and
it's perceived also as a common problem
and acted on you know to pick up the
newspaper there it is what are we doing
about that deficit so what is the u.s.
doing you know and here is what I find
on that it's very interesting I mean you
can see what other countries doing what
the Congress is doing generally speaking
american performance on that front is
about average there's there's nothing
exceptional about the u.s. it's not it's
not more spin thrifty or more stupid in
the way it does money on the other hand
it's right there with the pack so you
look at that and say oh well the US
anyway
it's not great the way almost any
country is doing this but still it's
probably unrealistic to expect that
countries are going to exceed greatly an
average se as they dead end to say you
shouldn't try but nonetheless there we
are now within that it's interesting to
see ca1 how do US and other countries
have handled the FISC or the you know
that deficit president all that so I
think and so forth starting in 2008 when
the Wall Street crisis came down that's
after all a big problem right there in
its own right and there the story is
quite interesting that is good or all
this by the way you have to look at what
the president's use doing I doubt the
Congress is doing so throughout the book
I look at the performance of the
presidency as well as the performance of
the Congress you have to do that you
have to partial out the presidency in
the Congress and try to get a fix on my
Congress distinctively is doing I think
he do anyway on that front it's quite
interesting to see the American
performance so to speak in the last five
six years or so for one thing the the in
responding to the wall street crisis
after all you know that they're it a the
crunch I mean they dip in the economy
the Great Recession they call it the
American counterfactual stimulus
spending spend money you know then Prime
Kenneth was was among the biggest or the
biggest as a perform as a percentage of
the economy and across you know some 30
countries in the developed world so
really the US was out front and in
spending money as would be would be
suggested by many economists after all
and trying to address this thing that's
mostly a presidential accomplishment it
comes down through early Obama a little
bit of it like bush / early Obama you
look at that you say there but still you
spend a lot of money even though it's a
good idea to do and you'd be running up
the deficit in the debt after all they
have to worry about that too but so that
is interesting that downstream from the
stimulus that came down under early
Obama the system cranked into getting
away from it that is in the after the
republicans took over the congress in
the mid terrace 2010 the next Congress
really cranked down on
and I'm on that a deficit where they
took a big bite out of through through
two point seven billion dollars from it
through the sequestration and and and
and at the fiscal cliff deal of our
leaders out there all that I mean all
it's very messy we hated it the
government shutdown in error a couple of
times we just hate what goes on the
optics of DC is terrible on these
matters but the at the end of the line
the after at bass of two thousand
fifteen or so the American Fisk is in
pretty good shape on this in this sense
we the result of its pretty good the and
they ask actual all the debt as
proportion of GNP is below a 40-year
average now no that's probably chiefly
because we're coming out of the
recession but nonetheless the government
handling of from this not everybody
agrees a good idea after all to do this
somewhat bleaching in the economy but
nonetheless from the standpoint of that
deficit the performance of the system
probably out of Congress is pretty good
that having been said I think that we
look back farther and take a closer or
more fine-grained look and probably over
long period of time the system is
somewhat dependent on the President to
keep a debt deficit in line Congress may
just edge a little bit toward being
profligate and foolish not greatly but
on average over her long period of time
is a considerable dependence probably on
the president's to be guardians of the
Fisk and we see some of them doing a
good job of it mean Clinton and Bush 41
the father and Eisenhower for example
some prize roseville is pretty good too
that surprisingly Franklin Roosevelt are
pretty good at guarding the Fisk we
depend to a certain degree on presidents
to do that well that is an interesting
point because I would imagine that
Congress works either with the President
or against the president I mean if you
look today President Obama has a very
difficult time with Congress and getting
Congress to do anything sure if you look
back at Reagan for instance a very
different story well they fought to you
know okay watch Joe sending that out
there what do you think about that I
mean in terms of Congress Congress's
imprint I think
sometimes it does have haven't have been
influenced by its relationship with the
sitting president well definitely me
very often after all and certainly on
these fiscal matters what grains out as
a result of dealing between the
president and the Congress which is
often conflictive I'd say it typically
conflictive big very seldom do you get
very anywhere near perfect agreement
between the White House on the one hand
the executive branch of the Congress on
the other any spending and taxing
matters so it's it's a grind all the way
through there's nothing new about that
it starts in 1789 there's nothing new
about that right it got sometimes it's
it exaggerated sin temor more open
conflict as recently that'll be when
there well when the one party has the
White House and the other has the
Congress for example oh I don't see any
evidence by the way that the actual
handling and the results of the Fisk
happens worse are the conditions of
divided product very unified party
control that's interesting although the
conflict is more open and nastier at
those times typically but it was there
under Reagan made Reagan against Tip
O'Neill on fiscal matters in the 80s was
recurrently recurrently a spectacle but
that Roosevelt used to fight with
Democratic Congress so I already
Franklin Roosevelt oh ok so how overall
how would you characterize Congress's
imprint on America up to this point well
you take it over 225 years is a long
time here are some of the things that
would be true I think that Congress is
very good at capacious representation of
voters put it that way now if you're not
a voter you're in trouble you don't
count and that's was a big problem
through both of American history with
suffers denial but for accommodating the
taste preferences intensities of various
parts of the voting population Congress
is pretty good an average better than
the president there's nothing surprising
about that that's what legislators do so
and it's really good I think on that and
doing that again you got to be a voter
and what that what will that mean is
you'll get a lot of conflict and still
made because this is a very
heterogeneous country all the way from
the beginning I mean the universe of
tastes out there an interest in
preference is really very heterogeneous
oh you got to expect you're going to
have a lot of fussing on Capitol
a lot of non-action but in action and
airship by somebody's judgment it's
always been going to be the case for
that part of the public is not going to
like what Congress is not doing or doing
that's just the way it is right the
public might not like what they're doing
but I would argue that the public has
nothing to do with Congress and what
they're doing it's the people who have
all the money the one-percenters control
this country yeah that's not right with
Congress now now campaign contributions
are pretty important but you take right
now I mean the right Nick Republicans
are having trouble on Capitol Hill you
know John Boehner and it is coalition of
the house they losing their some of the
right wingers are won't go along good
really in the hair rebated why is that
true well I mean if you're from the
Arkansas it's their district or from the
Tennessee 6th district you're a hero
back home for what you say what you do
so they don't have to go along with a
party nationally or the country
nationally but they can just um their
nose and they'll get reelected that's
very that's not a one-percent thing
that's what it's like back in the
Arkansas a third kind of thing and
that's the way it goes that's the way it
goes okay okay another other long-term
effects I think that Congress is the
u.s. is not very good at building at
sustaining complicated effective
efficient national bureaucracies me the
way the seeds of the Germans are the
French do it and I think it's been true
all the way back I think except for the
military no they all the way back I
think a reason for that is that Congress
is very meddlesome that is they they
don't like bureaucrats they don't fund
bureaucrats very well think of the IRS
today it's just it's it's it's a kind of
sand outfit but that's pretty much
because over many decades and
generations Congress doesn't doesn't
grease it well doesn't give it enough
money enough employees doesn't keep its
IT operations in line I mean that's
there and that's typical and they all
that and I once but is one I spin off of
that it's been written about political
scientists lay the American welfare
state is fairly small compared with
those in European countries and one read
that probably is that it go back a
century or so I mean the US was really
quite laggard and building effective
national bureaucracies the way the
Social Security Agency basically is but
the US was late there and that's that
problem I think that
another effect is that Congress in them
in foreign policy is it's got different
propensity from those of the presidency
mean the president's arm or the other
act action proactive they like to send
drones after you know their Jefferson
sends the fleet to North Africa and
eighty know the president's do that sort
of thing where it's Congress a more
insular there they don't like to spend
money abroad they don't like excursions
or adventures or abroad they they don't
like commitments or it when there's a
difference between the Institute's
usually there's not but when they differ
Congress had been bends toward the
insularity right now they're giving
Obama trouble on his arraign Iranian
there's nothing new about that they
voted down the Kyoto Protocol ninety
five to nothing under Clinton they did
that they do this the reluctant to enter
into international international
commitments array of international
adventures I mean when remember oh that
was for pollution write his name yes it
was that's correct yeah right that's
correct um now there there I mean
Congress going backwards egos 60s and
70s is really out front in regulatory
legislation and telling the environment
really i mean the Clean Air Act the
Clean Water Act does a congressional
enterprises but you get into
international commitments like the Kyoto
Protocol and they kind of draw back I
think that's partly for every day they
drew back from the World Court in the
1930s they drew back from the Versailles
Treaty in 1919 just a little bit of
reluctance to get into commitments it's
that or to work with others outside of
this country yeah yeah yeah that's right
it's the rats right that's that that's
on average you know they did a little
there but but also adventurous vtwin
remember a couple years ago or whenever
it was when Obama was it looked like he
wanted he wanted he wanted to he drew
her that red line and one of the bomb
Syria remember that that was going on
the president about the bomb something
that became apparent he was going to go
to Capitol Hill for approval of that I
think it became evident he went there
they turned him down so he drew back you
know there's a net that you know they
talk on Capitol Hill they but they're
probably going to vote him down I mean
that's what happened at the british
house of commons and they gave a camera
on the Prime Minister asked for such
authority a little before obama through
back and so for there's an instance of
those
aveeno talk talking a lot okay they talk
a lot but drawing back actually from
from doing something is is fairly common
otherwise let's see going back over a
long period of time what would I say I
think that let me make this distinction
if you look at 225 years of influence i
think that of a congressional influence
Congress it sometimes quite proactive in
in in regulatory policy that it's
regulating business regulating business
as with the environmental rigid
legislation of the 60s and 70s you go
back a century 22 railroad regulation
labor legislation there's a lot of it a
lot of a lot of initiative on Capitol
Hill through a need for various
stretches of history of regulating
business it's in America actually seen
American trademark setting up business
regulation through independent agencies
the Americans did that they learned how
to do that so I thought but but for but
no I think I know but the other side of
that or rather a different aspect of the
relation between the Congress in the
economy is that we don't have we don't
have we don't have public ownership
thing of things in the US and publicly
owned this that or another companies or
whatever I mean thinking about the US
government running the microsoft
business it seems it's kind of crazy to
think it could even be done and so as
see I think a reason for that is you try
to set up a you try to have the
government actually run some productive
Alfred productive agency unit like that
and Congress that going to meddle so
it's a clear up front that has probably
done a good idea well they stepped in
when Detroit was going on her with the
car industry oh yes well don't give a
subsidy that's not a problem and they
took it over briefly but then it went
back they did that but they didn't want
to run it they kept arm lengths from run
again they would subsidize it you know
they did that and any other got out of
the board and so forth but i gotta drew
back but they then actually they're
running those countries they get the
company see there is I mean you it's yes
I mean if you go down and say let's
let's propose a lot to have the
government run the steel industry ona
they pay you're crazy it's just not
going to work to be too much meddling so
I think a reason
for the unusual privateness of the of
industry in the u.s. going back away
back is that it's pretty clear that
Congress even though it's very good at
maybe go to regulating things it would
it's it's not good it's a standing an
environment in which the government
actually can conduct large important
operations so last question moving
forward do you you know what are your
thoughts on Congress and for the next
200 years for instance pretty much same
old same old er do you forecast any
change is happening well I I don't see
big changes I said I mean some big
changes can come about nobody knows
really nobody knows really if you good
but I think probably the best for cat
after all we've been going on for 225
years there's a lot of continuity in the
operations of it during that time as
there is a let's say the British
Parliament say you get this a lot there
it is their customs are enormous so on
it's it's a if it be if Congress
sometimes it gets it gets out of line it
does and does things that are they're
not popular but then as that are
shrinking back and I'm fussing with it
generally the public will take action
sometimes of the courts for example of
fifty years ago the the districting of
House districts was is really out of
line it got more and more out of line in
the 30s 40s and 50s where Brian the
Supreme Court did it moved in and and
reconstructed in a sense the district
base of the US House of Representatives
these things can happen I would say you
know our best bet is to just try to line
the way the trundling and lacking some
immense disaster like and then immense
disasters can happen you know like
severe security crises or you're an
asteroid hitting or whatever nuclear
attack in which case them of course you
can get the demand for a tightening up
of central control and in a system is no
question about that actually I think now
I want one thing that is a thought that
I have is that in foreign policy foreign
policy the there there's often a
loggerheads problem there and as I say
Congress 10 saw it insularity the
presidency saw it in action prone this
sometimes they just fight there it is
somebody wrote a book saying that
Congress may be may not be maybe aunt
anti-imperialism but it's auntie
executive so it's something I'm just the
friction between the institutions can
you have a fact I think that during
during the last century and a half or
two centuries actually as the US has
been expanding and expanded on North
American economy and expanded to be the
world hegemonic power in the you know
their 20th century the certain amount of
slack in the in the sense that the u.s.
had a lot of power a lot of resources so
it could make mistakes or it could have
they could have internal conflict and
confrontations and messiness that would
not be finally fatal to the world
although and if we are now willing into
a circumstance in which the u.s. is
relatively a declining power which is
probably what's going to happen over the
next 50 years or so why then the this
sometimes messiness and loggerheads
aspect of foreign policy making may
become more of a problem in a
circumstance of declining power they
will be less slack if we're declining
who's rising yeah relatively but if
we're declining the United States who
who do you think I'm interpersonal the
China sure it's not as if there's
necessarily conflicted relationship but
the the US as a share of world power and
money and resources is necessarily
declining so question about that given
the given the given given given China
given them India given and so on it's
just it's that's the way it goes be the
peak of the American proportions in
those respects was 1945 after World War
two when everybody else was in a
shambles or almost everybody but then
with recovery and so on there we are we
know that okay well it's been quite a
pleasure to sit here and talk with you
about this today the pleasure of a mate
and we will look forward to your book
the imprint of Congress coming out
toward the end of this year I hope so
okay okay good for more information
about professor Mayhew and his research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale edu
please be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale